[Musique]
selon des légendes anglo saxon le ne
serai plus vieux que l'humanité
il serait né de larmes tissu de la terre
les jets ont leur est condamné il
travaillait toute sa vie voilà pour la
légende quant à la réalité
tout si la 13e réunion j'ai dit moi même
bonjour monsieur voulait faire un petit
tour pour mutiler le but qui laissent
alors place y voyez suis l'assassin de
vigneault il a une bonne bouteille 21
ans
la lyonnaise interdit n'est
pas celui-là voyait
avec la bouteille toujours de la
bouteille la lia au co2
avec le petit futé bourton super mouche
c'est la même chose
partout
ça c'est le meilleur là
le punk hippie
alors au début j'ai acheté 3 n'est toi
ça c'est bien ça c'est joli à l'ops a
commencé on allait en a chez dizaine
très joli et consoles a démarré
maintenant on est arrivés à trois sur os
3 0 c'est ouais je suis là je préfère
maintenant je suis là avec la bière vous
voyez comme je suis et trapu bertheux
pierre clatot celui-là pourquoi pas plus
que beaucoup plus que ma femme qui est
ce que vous pensez donc c'est tranquille
les nems vous semblait pas ils disent
pas dit mauresmo
avec des mets ça sur lui ses deux
rivales là je les adore
les nains de jardin certes un visa d'or
d'autres essaient de raconter leur
histoire moi je suis assez d'accord pour
imaginer une
généalogie du nain de jardin une ligne
et une descendance ou une ascendance
que
j'aime assez ces deux origines possibles
fait qu'ils sont pour la première priape
divinité desjardins pauvres à rome et
qui était une divinité assez piteuse
quoi pas qui était une des unités de la
fécondité qu'on installés dans l'est
dans les vergers dans permis les
troupeaux et c'est donc c'était une
espèce de deux divinités un peu
burlesque et on retrouve cette
familiarité
aujourd'hui avec le nain qu'on a dans
son jardin parce que on a un peu pitié
il est charmant il est mignon s'agit pas
de c'est pas une statue grecque quoi il
ya aussi cet autre origine qui est
plutôt saine
de la blanche neige de walt disney c'est
à ce
mineur du moyen-âge qui
avait
travaillé dans les profondeurs dans des
terrains extrêmement dure et donc
c'était des personnes de petite taille
qui pouvaient s'y glisser et ces
personnes de petite taille dont la tête
était recouverte d'un bonnet rempli de
mode de terre pour les protéger et les
poulies et dont les en effet les
vêtements de travail en cuir souvent
était en cuir teintées de couleurs très
vives pour pouvoir être trouvée de
manière plus facile dans les éboulis
une origines mythologiques priape le
compagnon des ânes comme le nain de
jardin une origine historique la 1000
voilà donc d'où viendrait notre
figurines
mettre des puissances dans la nature
connaisseur des trésors de la terre ce
personnage de mineurs seraient sortis
des entrailles des montagnes pour entrer
dans nos jardins par quel mystère une
science y répondent clame à nos jeunes
et la nano jeunesse espèces de faune de
meaux a forgé pour dire tout le mystère
qui entoure la naissance des nains et
bien sûr la naissance des nains de
jardin on en connaît une matérialisation
ancien qui date de l'époque antique
retrouvée dans une épave au large de la
tunisie this était censé orner le jardin
d'une villa d'une colonie romaine et
pour les archéologues c'est le premier
nains de jardin ensuite il y à un espèce
de grand trou noir ou bien sûr il ya des
figurations de nord mais il faut
retrouver retrouver la période de la
renaissance à période dite moderne pour
rencontrer les nains de cours lena de
cours d'un lieu à des représentations
sculptées et le plus connu d'entre eux
est le no more gong tai le nain de la
cour des médicis et vous trouvez ce nain
à l'entrée du jardin de boboli à
florence ensuite vous avez les gravures
de jacques callot cet artiste français
qui s'est promenée en italie au début du
xviie siècle qui deviennent le modèle
pour un ensemble de sculptures denain
pour l'époque baroque et on en connaît à
peu près 300 exemple qui se trouvent
dans les jardins des abbayes et château
de ce qui est maintenant aujourd'hui
l'autriche et l'allemagne
essentiellement la nano génèse nous
emmène donc en allemagne au château de
weyersheim dans le bade wurtemberg au
milieu de l'époque baroque grave car
ludwig von raul est fait dessiner un
magnifique jardin à la française qu'il
peuple d'une galerie d'un représentant
de façon caricaturale le personnel du
château ces statues illustre pleinement
le concept de grotesque maroc le baroque
magnifie les corps dieu ou athlètes aux
muscles saillants
[Musique]
face à eux le grotesque baroque propose
des silhouettes difforme des positions
tordu des visage anguleux
lilliputiens antithèse des canons
esthétiques
le xviiie siècle se clôt mais l'histoire
du nain de jardin ne fait que commencer
ensuite après cette période du xviie et
xviiie siècles on arrive aux 19e et le
19e siècle bien sûr c'est le moment de
la deûle à des identités nationales et
dans l'identité germanique apparaît les
frères grimm donc qui qui crée ses
comptes et le nain et vers la fin du 19e
siècle dans les années 1870 dans une
petite ville qu'on appelle graffeurs
rodas qui était habitué à la production
de céramiques des céramiques de petits
animaux de chasseurs et bien ces petites
manufactures créé le nom de jardin et
voilà
il est né le divin myrmidon
kleynhoff dans
ce pays de thuringe au 19e siècle est un
pays de forêts de montagne de mines un
graphe un rodin le sol riche en argile
fait proliférer des artisans potiers
parmi eux philippe guibert cet artisan
et est spécialisée dans les animaux en
terre cuite animaux sauvages chasser
dans la forêt puis afficher dans le
salon animaux domestiques étrangement
figé dans les années 1880 l'idée lui
vint de créer un personnage inspiré des
paysans allemands en référence aux
mineurs il affuble d'un bonnet rouge et
d'un tablier de cuir cette figurine va
traverser le xxème siècle qu'elle fait
bannis par les nazis qui les
considéraient comme de détestable
symbole petit bourgeois puis elle
représente à une horrible incarnation de
la propriété privée sous l'allemagne
communiste qui l'interdît sauf bien sûr
à l'exportation et c'est le plastique
qui dans les années 60 est permis de
conquérir le monde et de faire comme ici
de celle du rocher quoi bon alors on
mettait ça pour faire de la couleur
les sûretés tous les week-ends mais là
on est plus connue des comme on rajeunit
pas où l'essor les longs week-ends au
[Musique]
chez ce couple c'est tous les week-ends
que les nains envahissent le jardin de
leur maison de campagne
[Musique]
c'est comme ça on savoir les couleurs
de peur d'être volée mais surtout pour
ne pas rester seule pendant la semaine
les quelque 100 en un attendent le
week-end sagement dans le garage
après une demi heure trois quarts
d'heure autan volley ronger
pourquoi tu peux pas savoir mais quand
il se
sait pas gay
[Musique]
en plus des enfants
et voilà les nains ont envahi le jardin
envahi au point d'en chasser les 40 et
les haricots qu'un à l'origine le jardin
populaire était un lieu de production
son histoire a commencé dans les années
30 avait clamé lemire et ses jardins
ouvriers et à l'époque quand le rouge
apparaissait c'était une tomate est pas
le bonnet d'un un jardin potiron contre
nantes jardin comment ce farfadets
remporter cette bataille ligne en 1969
la création du premier concours des
maisons fleuries qui a connu dès la
première édition un énorme succès et qui
a concouru à la création de tous ses
magasins type garden center qui ont pour
fonction de fournir comme ça aux
nouveaux jardiniers la somme des
ornements des décorations pour la façade
du pavillon et son jardin c'est le
moment où le jardin quitte ce terrain de
la production pour devenir un outil dans
une compétition qui est celle du
standing donc le jardin devient l'enjeu
d'un standing et dont une compétition
sociale on s'affiche dans son jardin on
s'étale dans son jardin et le jardin est
devenu un moyen de s'exprimer
voilà mon domaine
c'est recréer la nature ici la voir chez
moi
j'aime tellement la pêche du poisson
l'on jette une image hors des suicides
s'acquiert bon mon café je délaisse le
décor paraissent commandés quand j'ai
débuté par des nerfs en pelote qui sort
casser aussi facilement dont j'ai trouvé
sénat en résine qui m'ont l'air un peu
plus solide mais enfin qui casse quand
même
jean ses positions sont plus coloré plus
du gué bon c'est 6 millions pourquoi y
résister
bah j'aime bien le pain gens que j'aime
l'idée d'un pêcheur
avec un petit poisson artistique ça
ressort
voilà les photos j'ai tiré la communion
de la fir et j'en ai profité pour
l'attirer sur le banc ça là c'est le
blanchissage en nature
et pauline à
leurs guerres leur garçon souriant du
hayon ya pas des tpo divers pour eux
sont toujours en train de sourire et ça
qui est bien
[Musique]
le nord a le visage tourné vers le
voisin m 1 1 dans son jardin c'est
présenter son univers à ses voisins un
univers onirique un rêve d'enfance le
nain construit un espace plus grand que
l'espace du jardin en convoquant
l'imaginaire en faisant appel à la
miniaturisation
[Musique]
les explications que je donnerais mois
plus sûr c'est la prolifération des
nains de jardin c'est cette image
immédiate de bonheur sans
conceptualisations qui c'est à dire ce
bonheur vous saute aux yeux il vous
permet une certaine confidences
vous pouvez vous confier à houdain le
jardin il ne bougera pas il ne changera
pas il ne vous répondra pas le même
jardin
bien des égards peut être considéré
comme le freud du pauvre c'est-à-dire
comme quelque chose qui permet à la fois
de revisiter son enfance de se remémorer
son enfance et un confident qui comme le
psychanalyste ne vous répondra pas qui
vous écoutera sans conséquence
bonjour les petits as déjà siffloter ce
matin dit
là comme ça tient un peu mieux
voilà
la blanche neige qui vous qui vous garde
qui veuille bien sûr eu un mais bien sûr
dommage que le papa n'est plus là n'en
fait un pays
il avait du plaisir avec vous mais oui
tu as pu t'en fiches sur ton petit
cochonnet c'est la belle vie
ouais
et puis les deux sas et les deux petits
coquins ferait bientôt un petit frère
d'accord
bien avoir mon petit gamin
voilà nous voilà encore un nouveau dire
tu vois les rejoint ses deux petits
copains là bas il va te maîtrise
s'arrête
vous devrez déplacer en métro mais
si tu peux pas
lui mettre
du coeur
voilà comme ça
voilà où étaient copains les zombies
joli petit
le grand avantage du nain de jardin
c'est que il ne produit pas de nuisances
dans l'environnement et pour son
propriétaire lui même c'est à dire que
il en vient à représenter une espèce
d'idéal ornementale parce que on peut
s'adresser à lui lui parler comme aux
chats aux chiens ou aux cochons d'inde
ou et aux oiseaux dans la cage mais il a
ceci en plus en terme de confort c'est
qu'il ne se reproduit pas c'est qu'on
risque pas de se retrouver avec une
portée de nains de jardin devant sont
devant son seuil un matin de printemps
dit que c'est la chaîne donc ça c'est un
grand plus pour
[Musique]
les nas on est dans les ateliers des
potiers il y a plus d'un siècle
mais aujourd'hui rares sont les artisans
qui continuent à perpétuer cette
tradition en alsace à marmoutier
jean-claude ernenwein a repris l'atelier
de son père pour continuer la production
de lin en céramique émaillée les naseaux
fabriqué à partir d'argile mêlait de
l'eau les mollets temps poreux ils
absorbent l'eau élargi vient se fixer
sur les parois
les excédents d'argile sont reversés
afin d'obtenir un un creux qui résistera
aux tensions de four à 1030 degrés
[Musique]
les nains sont sortis des moules
ils sont finis manuellement on leur
ajoute éventuellement des petits
accessoires moulay à part comme les
mains ou les outils
je
senna en céramique émaillée viendront
décorer les jardins on les sortira au
printemps et on les rentrera en automne
comme les géraniums
chacun est unique pain selon
l'inspiration de l'artisan
à
épier propre et puis on va au four
alors qu'il y a quelques années produire
un nain de jardin pour un artisan potier
qui était un sujet de raillerie
aujourd'hui les nains de jean-claude
ernenwein font l'objet de réelles
collection et d'une distribution
mondiale via internet
fabriqué à partir de moules créé en 1932
ces statuettes représentent les figures
typiques denain
car la figure du nain fascine lorient
dre du jardin ce lutin rajeunie à
travers le siècle
vieillard à barbe à la fin du 19e siècle
aujourd'hui son visage poupon intrigue
le processus de séduction du nain de
jardin l'a obligé à rajeunir pour
quitter son image négative de mineurs et
devenir un personnage jeune et
sympathique
c'est en république tchèque que ice
nerfs premier producteur mondial de
nains de jardin a installé son usine
à 50 km de prague habchi drame la
société figure à plast produit tous les
ans plus de 110000 nains de jardin en
plastique
la collection comporte plus de 200
modèles de ceux de quelques centimètres
à ceux de plus d'un mètre les nains sont
produits à partir de moules en cuivre ou
en week-end
[Musique]
du pvc liquide écoulée dans chacun de
ces moules
les moules sont regroupés et montés sur
des plateaux
les plateaux tourner à 360 degrés pour
permettre au père et ses d'adhérer
uniformément aux parois ses moules font
un séjour de quelques minutes dans un
four à 270 degrés puis sont refroidies
[Musique]
les nains sortie des moules encore
chauds sont mous ils durciront en
refroidissant
non
la société ait nerfs a été fondée en
1872 agrafes émeraude dans la ville de
naissance du nain de jardin
après la seconde guerre mondiale elle a
quitté l'allemagne de l'est pour
s'installer à lauterbourg
depuis 1964
elle produit des noms en plastique
incassable moins cher ils ont permis
l'essor du nain de jardin en 1996
haffner décide de produire sénat en
plastique en république tchèque tous les
ans les designers créent plus de 20
nouveaux modèles les nains sont tous
peints à la main chaque ouvrière pour
atteindre 2,8 à 120 par jour selon la
taille et la difficulté
les nains pas dans ses mains douces
expertes
à
pour y gagner la petite flamme qui
brillera dans leurs yeux et égayera
leurs propriétaires
m
premier producteur mondial à isner se
partagent le marché avec deux autres
firme autrichienne vo et lieberman
face à ces fabricants on voit émerger
des contrefacteurs denain aux frontières
de l'allemagne
que ce soit avec la pologne ou avec la
république tchèque des petites boutiques
proposant des décorations de jardin
prolifèrent
sénat sont principalement produit en
pologne ou en asie ce sont des
représentations de moins bonne qualité
aux traits grossiers ils vivront un
hiver avant de se casser ou de perdre
leurs couleurs le marché du net ainsi
envahi de copies sans âme marché du nain
de jardin alors il est saisonnier pour
commencer c'est un marché qui démarre au
printemps principalement avec les beaux
jours qui reviennent c'est un marché qui
est en progression
dans
dans beaucoup de régions principalement
dans la partie nord et nord-est de la
france les fournisseurs sont en chine
donc ce sont des fabricants de céramique
à qui nous confions la fabrication de
différents modèles ou qu'ils nous
proposent eux des designs des nains de
jardin qui sont réputés ou déjà reconnu
en europe nous récupérerons entre
guillemets d'une année sur l'autre les
modèles qui ont bien fonctionné qui ont
été fermés car en grande série nous
avons souvent un temps de décalage on a
importé à peu près 35 mm jardin cette
année les gens aient vraiment quand ils
achètent sont heureux d'acheter un
édifice parle d lorna qu'ils ont ce
qu'ils ont dans leur jardin ça fait
partie vraiment de leur jardin on voit
là par exemple un chut
c'est un play
il ya une des plus grosses ventes au
niveau de la gamme pierre vous avez
également donc cette qualité là était un
don quand une résine de deux déjà de
très très belles qualités mais notre n'a
donc est plus petit en taille en
ont claqué le napt pêcheurs le nain
brouette le nez avec
le petit lapin je vais vous présenter un
autre nom mais pas en vente directe donc
elle n'a en général que les gens
achètent pour faire des blagues
pour l'anecdote
c'est le travailleur quand même c'est
quand même le travailleur le nain ne
veut pas envisager au début or du
travail de la mine du jardin la brouette
l'appel
la langue tu permet de descendre dans
les profondeurs
nature risque pas de grandir avec ça et
puis le nain de jardin se relâche un peu
et on lui permet quelques loisirs après
être passé par sa période musicien qui
était un peu une période intermédiaire
parce que c'est encore un travail que de
jouer de la musique eh bien ma foi
maintenant il filait sur des transats il
pêche à la ligne et les bois beaucoup de
bière et ça va pour lui quoi le nain de
jardin entre de son ère du second degré
à
lavaltrie marc dumas est de règle dans
le maryland el yamani
marc
ribot et
d'assassinats repassera en libye tri
parmi les séries manque de rythme
la cour a aussi
[Musique]
fabriqué en un jardin c'est une
profession de foi cela peut être aussi
un véritable passe temps
alors ce passionné visite les jardins à
la recherche de nouveaux modèles donne
un psy lui plaisent il est emprunté on
fabrique un moule pour pouvoir les
reproduire chez lui dans la tex et à
celui-là avec la tondeuse
elle est alors plusieurs couches jusqu'à
obtenir une épaisseur
et après je le retire comme une
chaussette
c'est de la peinture acrylique beaucoup
de couleurs que je fais moi même pas
j'essaye de jeu touche mais le moins
possible d'argent de danse et c'est là
tout l'attrait peintre de nains de
jardin le soir il est électricien le
jour alors pourquoi ne pas allier ces
deux activités donc là j'ai pris un an
est d'ailleurs un modèle très anciens
jeux les percées ont été remontés haut
jusqu'en bas j'ai fait un saut que
l'envoi j'ai passé une tige filetée et
je les électrifier promettant un
abat-jour fait lampe de chevet
[Musique]
le nain devient l'objet d'un qu on le
vénère dans des parcs d'attractions
comme à trouver et à halle en allemagne
dans l'agglo de réserve en angleterre le
port du bonnet rouge est impose aux
visiteurs pour ne pas déranger les
activités du nain mais ces parts ne
répondent pas aux questions
fondamentales qui tourne autour du lit
qu'elle laisse sa sexualité existe-t-il
une naine de jardin pour répondre à ces
questions essentielles
le professeur fritz friedman a créé une
nouvelle science
la nano logis la nano la chine ça fait
la fille ans que nous avons fondé elle
vient du mot nanou ce qui est latin et
10 9 et 10 mo lo ce qui est grec et qui
titille ans donc l'analogique c'est la
science sur les nerfs chardin
la nano logis tient son congrès en
bretagne il convient de mesurer que le
présent congrès en lui même est un
révélateur construit qui en agitant le
nain de jardin et en le sortant de son
cadres supposés qu'est le jardin nous
permet par les réactions qu'il provoque
de comprendre notre monde
agité le nain de jardin est un
révélateur social tout à fait singulier
et pertinents qui échappe à l'étude
statistique pour entrer sur le champ
plus complexes des représentations et
des émotions sociales tentative de
grandir avec effraction votre compte est
bon est ce que le nain de jardin a une
âme et sur ma droite vous trouvez la
plus grande production actuelle
industrielle de nains de jardin c'est 1
1 qui fait environ un mètre de haut en
plastique et puis au centre comme
surtout de table vous avez un un
baigneur qui est en céramique et chez
les nanos log les spécialistes des nains
de jardin on estime que le nain en terre
a une âme et le nain en plastique n'en a
pas évidemment il est difficile de
conclure sur ce douloureux sujet je
crois que simplement il faut laisser la
question ouverte et le possesseur se
pose lui-même la question et trouvent
souvent la réponse doit aujourd'hui
gérer voire honteux de grain de malice
alors qu'est ce que tu vas me le dire
est ce qu'aujourd'hui j'ai positif et
bah tu vois pas besoin de poser la
question que tout le monde tendu de
paris donc il est uniquement parce que
c'est pas positif elle ne dit pas que
c'est parce que c'est du plastique ça
devrait pas de positif
nous avons fait une différence entre un
indécent qui correspondance aux
exigences bonnet rouge
tablier ou un veston loire ou moins
ouvert des portes forte et de temps en
temps avec une lanterne ça ce n'est
décembre
ici vous voyez pas dîner lé sens parce
que j'aime pas les montre ici par notre
conversation
lena est décent sont ceux avec un
couteau dans le dos ou ceux qui se
débattent des habits à moitié ici vous
voyez une production pourrait centre qui
a été fait contrairement aux règles de
l'analogie passe nous disons il y a que
des nains de sexe masculin il a produit
cette figurine horrible pour un
orthodoxe pour faire plaisir à ses nains
comme il a dit parce qu'ils sont
demandés depuis des années
j'ai fait des semaines et depuis des
jours une company men mais nous pourrons
pas la reconnaître je me montre à titre
l'augmentation paie pas du tout à titre
d'approbation il ya quelque chose comme
ça c'est un scandale je vais plus
d'avoir on est entouré de bonnet denain
à ces protubérances qui permet d'évoquer
un aspect assez
emblématique est un peu mystique si je
puis me permettre l'expression du nain
de jardin c'est sa sexualité il ya un
petit peu deux tendances qui donneront
un petit peu l'esprit de la sexualité du
nain de jardin il ya d'abord le nain de
jardin qui est asexué c'est à dire que
il est toujours dans son travail
toujours en train de creuser sa galerie
de mineurs et donc il n'a jamais le
temps de résoudre sont complexes et dit
bien et donc le pauvre il reste dans une
sexualité totalement amorphe et atone
et en revanche s'oppose à ça dans la
lignée de ce que l'on disait à propos de
priape le nain avec la sexualité
débridée et là la littérature regorge
d'anecdotes croustillantes à ce sujet ou
le nain serait un peu le fantasme de ces
dames et permettrait tous les délires
sexuelle
[Musique]
à
oh
l'analogie est une science qui s'exerce
avec 100% sérieux et 100% d'humour
avec la nano logis le nain s'est échappé
du jardin pour s'inviter dans la société
semble on
est très simple on
jeté deux fois mythos
ce qui ne l'est pas fumer la
parfumerie
ce farfadets a traversé le siècle sur
des chocs sur des verts comme vide
poches
copier
qui peut être ouverts en porcelaine en
bois
en bronze
considéré comme porte bonheur il est
vite apparu sur des cartes de voeux puis
dans la publicité connaissant les
secrets de la nature il ventait des
aliments ou des boissons inventif et
imaginatif et lui arrivait de
représenter des innovations techniques
après les années 30 il disparaît de
cette iconographie pour ne réapparaître
que récemment dans des publicités à la
télévision ce que pense alain de jardin
son essai de se projeter c'est que ce
que je fous j'ai envie de me barrer et
puis de voir autre chose et trouver une
blanche neige et de finir mes lire
lesquels plutôt que d'être la côte et
donc ne t'est l'univers de snom jardin
qui bouge était pas très loin de
l'univers de burton avec ces espèces de
personnages pas balle semblait assez
pervers ce qui lui plaisait dû justement
c'était ce côté
pervers et lubriques donc il est allé à
fond là-dedans enfin on était obligé de
censure et pas mal de plans parce que le
petit note pourrait y avait une file
d'attenté de gens qu'est le cinéma et
soulever les jupes des filles pour mater
leurs culottes y avait pleins pleins
petit
deux des seuls détails comme ça qui me
retenait lever 1 et qui n'ont pas pu
passer parce que parce qu'il voulait la
nuit dans le trash et publicité
aujourd'hui utilisent non pas de nain de
jardin tel qu'il est avec dans sa
relation avec les propriétaires les
relations de bonheur aux actions du
média pts et de simplicité de joie il
utilise un jardin sur l'image qui va par
ailleurs c'est à dire ça mais mauvais
goût
là les publicités vont caricaturer le
nain de jardin en le présentant comme
qu'un personnage agressif par news
méchant donc les gens viennent vérifier
qu'effectivement ils ne sont pas de ce
bord c'est-à-dire de ce bord des
amateurs de nos jardins
[Musique]
bien avant de passer à la télévision le
na rayon fait sur le grand écran lors de
ses 17 n'en rapporte beaucoup et re en
termes de notoriété et de popularité ou
on a mineurs mais retour beaucoup en
termes d'esprit aux nains de jardin
peut-être qu'on envisage est tel que
l'envisagent bettelheim bruno bettelheim
par exemple dit le nain et cette figure
près adamique pré adolescentes
prépubères
dépourvu d'esprit
dont l'intelligence est encore
indéfiniment en gestation
et donc privé d'individualités or
première décision de walt disney il faut
personnaliser
ses nains donc leur attribuer des
caractères de manière un peu
caricaturale ya grincheux il ya
donc là on bouscule un peu l'image
traditionnelle du dans le jardin est un
bon soir de semaine un jardin alors les
thèmes abordés dans les chansons des
nains de jardin c'est tout ce qu'ils les
touchent de près
les choses que tout le monde connaît mon
tonton coupe
tout peut toucher tout le monde peut pas
toucher à ces domaines là un autre
jardin c'est plus facile à aborder
que la vénus de milo quoi lorsque j'ai
dix neuf vous répétez après moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est dans mon jardin
dans le golan diana
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
leur bataille
bon
l'artiste contemporain s'est approprié
le nain de jardin pensons à tous ces
grands artistes du xxème siècle ce n'est
pas des artistes de seconde zone ben
jeff koons et bien sûr le fameux groupe
d'artistes présence panchounette s'est
dissous avec un geste fascinant la
création de nains de jardin
surdimensionné et on constate même
philippe starck un grand designer connu
qui s'est approprié le nain de jardin il
a créé ces tabourets nains de jardin et
si lui a utilisé cet objet je crois que
on peut lui rendre hommage il est
toujours là où il faut être et souvent
avant tout le monde et je crois qu'une
fois de plus c'est un témoignage
oui le nain été enlevé du jardin
rockeur artistes stars de cinéma
aux dernières nouvelles on l'aurait
croisée sur internet où quelques
spécimens serait à vendre mais il aurait
disparu des pelouses qu'a fait la police
à saverne 174,1 ont été saisis dans une
cache leurs propriétaires viennent à la
gendarmerie les reconnaître
avec le smic là ça
c'est probable
marange bateau parce que l
[Applaudissements]
avec eux champions les bourses
bon on a juste dans l'aune des gens qui
les avait bien marqué en dessous donc je
veux dire la bleue au pérou qui avait
notre lait qui sont venus avec des
caméscopes un don qu'ils étaient filmés
ou les photos que j'en aie a pas de
problème pour certaines les enfants nous
actuellement acheté beaucoup la fête des
pères alors
mais l'année dernière c'est garros m oui
l'année dernière c'est
ridicule
et ce en
vue là malheur et la justice vis à vis
d'un chalet nous étions obligés de
fonder l'association hêtre nationale
pour la protection des neiges charvin
qui existe maintenant plus qu'à 20 ans
et qui a déjà assez bonne réputation
surtout encore après ce qui s'est passé
en france et en belgique avec les front
de libération
mais en dehors de sam nous devons
protéger les n'est pas seulement qu'on
s'échange incriminant été mais également
contre la
concurrence déloyale si un emploi le
nain pourpre fait la publicité pour un
produit qui n'a rien à faire avec les
nains chardin et nous les protéger
contre les mauvaises langues que si par
exemple vous dites n'importe quel
politicien et un un char 20t pas une
violation pour ce politicien une
violation pour le match face à ceux qui
les défendent ceux qui les libère nous
on les vend de la viande en déclarant la
libération totale tous les noms nous
avons décidé de le sortir de leur jardin
pour le remettre dans leur milieu
naturel la forêt le lac
êtres séquestrés sont maltraités
sans parler des humiliations
quotidiennes
et du stress
il mérite mieux que d'être enfermé dans
cet espace où ils n'ont aucune chance de
pouvoir se reproduire c'est pourquoi
nous avons décidé de ne mettre pas c'est
terrible sort le redonner une chance de
pouvoir s'en sortir et de commencer une
nouvelle vie
chère propriétaire nous tenons à vous
dire que tous vos n'avons bien et qu'ils
profitent de leur liberté rome à
l'horizon les héros rendons-leur la
place qu'ils méritent dans notre source
haïti non viraux notre jardin vive la
forêt
même le jardin de bagatelle qui a voulu
rendre hommage au nom a été victime du
fln
jean et dans les années 90 qui souhaite
remettre les nains de jardin dans leurs
territoires naturels selon ce groupe
donc
qui seraient des forêts est venu à
bagatelle estimant qu à bagatelle le
n'étaient pas libérés je ne suis pas
vraiment d'accord l'accepterons puisque
d'abord à bagatelle le nain est anobli
ensuite ils sont libérés puisqu'ils sont
arrachés à leurs collectionneurs pour le
temps d'une exposition temporaire et
donc ils sont également dans le bois de
boulogne qui est un territoire naturel
par définition bon les front de
libération des nains de jardin n'a pas
jugé juste ce point de vue et ils sont
venus libérer une dizaine d'industriels
nous attendons leur libération on a vu
apparaître le front de libération des
nains de jardin en à peu près tous et
tous ces groupes est en fait on comme
comme plaisir le fait de mettre en
difficulté les personnes qui ont les
nains de jardin de le ridiculiser aux
yeux de tous à travers ce jeu social on
voit aussi apparaître des critiques
sociales c'est à dire on va parler des
bouffes de ces beaufs qui ont des nains
de jardin on va parler de
libérer les nains jardin des beaufs qui
les possèdent donc il ya une vraie
critique de l'art populaire de la
culture populaire je dirais il y en a
plus l'impression que depuis que le
bizutage est interdit dans les écoles
dans les grandes écoles il réinvente
notre forme de visite le bizutage social
le flnj est née en 1996 à alençon ce
n'était tout d'abord qu'une blague
subversif d'étudiants mais alors que la
branche historique s'est dissoute au
bout de six mois des personnes mais
encore régulièrement des actions
terroristes contre les nains ou en se
revendiquant du fln j comme si les
valeurs du fln j avais trouvé un écho
dans notre société comme si le nahd
jardin susciter un réel débat comme si
débarquant dans notre univers le nom
nous poser des questions essentielles
vous vous trouvez ici devant la serre
que nous avons restauré
lainelle ont envahi l'ennemi juré de
l'ars et le bon goût disait picasso le
château de beaumanoir quant à lui est
l'ami de l'art contemporain mettre les
gens en face d'eux mêmes à travers un
média qui est l'art contemporain
aujourd'hui ce média s'est donné les
armes classiques tout le monde les
troupes de bon goût le lourd tout le
monde trouve ça très beau c'est au
louvre le gouffre pose à partir ge a
besoin d'eux pour moi tu 19e siècle et
encore plus du 20e siècle alors si je ne
me trompe le nas est répandu au 19e
siècle la fin du 19e siècle a été
commercialisé et c'est peut-être à ce
moment là qu'on prend dans des petits
jardins des jardins ouvriers les jardins
simple on a dit mais là c'est presque
acquis social un point du social art
n'avait alors menace était aussi une
manière de se poser la question du goût
différent
le mans est à la mode la mode est au
kitsch le nain kitsch le kitsch c'est la
production en masse la consommation au
mas et ce n'est pas par hasard si jean
charles de castelbajac a choisi les
allées d'un grand magasin pour son
défilé de haute couture qui honore les
neiges hard
[Musique]
le nahd jardin est d'origine allemand le
pitch est d'origine allemand le kitsch
c'est produire en masse des biens qui
avaient la caractéristique des pony
mille gravure reproduite ne valent pas
un tableau mais il n'a sorti d'un moule
ne valent pas une simple clic le pitch
c'est ce mensonge qui veut faire croire
que ça comme gm valeur alors qu'il n'est
plus unique le pitch n'est donc pas une
catégorie esthétique c'est un mode de
comportement
le nike kitsch parce qu'il est reproduit
à l'infini
maintenant
je
crois que
ma
forme
a ni police ni fils et andreu
il ya à la fois d'alain comme
himalaya du mauvais goût une envie de
paradoxes chef-d'oeuvre ou nullité
laborieux ou paresseux sexualité
débridée ou abstinence totale réaliste
ou légendaires verre ou plastique avec à
moussan am décent ou indécent protéger
ou libérer formes simples du bonheur ou
dégénérescence du goût choisir un nain
c'est prendre parti
[Musique]
mais petit chou pas kitsch bon goût au
mauvais goût ou même mauvais goût trait
dessus ce qui compte pour le nain de
jardin c'est le plaisir qu'il apporte à
son propriétaire
les nets
[Musique]
enfants j'adore
cher à ses amis et moi il faut que du
maroc j'adore les bêtes mais j'en veux
pas et qu'il ait nine font pas de saleté
je dépose en jardin gels arte avec eux
vous les mettez sa forte leveaux ont des
envies de sa jeunesse et la vérité
genre nouveau parti de famille qui ne
parlent pas mais
[Musique]
je suis là
je me mets devant
comme ça et l'autre côté aussi et comme
ça comme ça toute la semaine ces bases
le temps passe les retraités
c'est donc ça le nain une touche de
chaleur une touche de couleur et le nain
dans tout cela qu'est ce qu'ils en
pensent il s'en moque un peu il est
amoureux de la rose et ça lui suffit et
comme tous les contes de fées cela
finira bien il épousera la rose avec la
bénédiction de la grue devant une
assemblée d'invités endimanchés
et la rosée lui auront beaucoup le petit
nain qui naîtront dans des fleurs mais
laissons le mot de la fin professeur
frydman
dans la technologie moderne le mot nano
vous la voyez partout aussi bien dans
les ordinateurs que dans la plaie du
free des atomes partout aujourd'hui tous
minimaliste ça prouve que les petits et
grands
on les nomme
jardin évitons sur l'eau verte
lévrier c est trop
oh